madame monsieur bonjour la princesse de
galles lady di est morte cette nuit à
paris dans un accident de voiture elle
se trouvait avec son ami le milliardaire
saoudien dodi al fayed mort lui aussi
ainsi que le chauffeur de la voiture un
employé de l'hôtel ritz le garde du
corps de lady di lui est grièvement
blessé lady di et dodi al fayed était
arrivé hier à paris au sortir du ritz un
modèle qui appartient au père de dodi al
fayed leur voiture une mercedes noire a
été prise en chasse par des paparazzi
l'accident a eu lieu dans le tunnel du
pont de l'alma vers minuit le chauffeur
a perdu le contrôle de la mercedes qui
roulait semble-t-il à très très vive
allure dodi al fayed et le chauffeur
sont semble-t-il mort sur le coup la
princesse elle est décédée quatre heures
plus tard à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière sur ces événements de la
nuit le récit de pascal golomer
[Musique]
des tôles déchiqueté le moteur broyer
l'état de la voiture témoigne de la
violence extrême du choc il est zéro
enfant lorsque lady diana quittent le
restaurant de c'est en compagnie de son
nouveau dit al-fayed un chauffeur de
l'hôtel est au volant un agent de
sécurité de la princesse à ses côtés
mais la voiture est poursuivi par
plusieurs photographes à moto elle
pénètre dans le tunnel de l'alma en
plein paris à 100 150 km/heure peut être
plus le chauffeur perd le contrôle et la
voiture percute très violemment les
parois du tunnel lorsque la police et
les secours arrivent sur les lieux de
dial fayed est déjà décédé tout comme le
chauffeur la princesse de galles elle
doit être désincarcéré l'opération prend
plus d'une heure avant le transfert à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
l'enquète débute tout juste les
photographes sont interrogés les motos
saisies comme pièces à conviction
mais à 5h50 à l'hôpital le professeur
riou patron de l'équipe de réanimation
convoque la presse
en évidence une plaie importante de la
veine pulmonaire gauche malgré la
fermeture de cette plaie et un massage
cardiaque externe et interne de deux
heures aucune efficacité circulatoire
n'a pu être rétablie et le décès a été
constaté à 4 heures du matin quant aux
journalistes photographes ils sont
toujours entendus quai des orfèvres par
les enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle
jean pierre chevènement le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est rendu au chevet de la
princesse de galles il exprimé la grande
peine et l'émotion du peuple français
jean pierre chevènement
j'adresse les condoléances de la france
à la famille royale
aux familles des victimes
et au peuple britannique tout entier
lady diana était une personne très aimé
en france une crainte de moderne pour
age 2
sensible à la détresse humaine
sa disparition sera ressentie
douloureusement
dans d'autres pays
jacques chirac a également exprimé sa
vive émotion à la rochelle ou et
participe aux universités d'été du parti
socialiste lionel jospin a indiqué qu'il
rentrait sur paris pour s'incliner
devant la dépouille mortelle de lady di
à londres bien sûr l'émotion est
également très vive le premier ministre
tony blair s'est déclaré choqué et
attristé par ce qu'il considère comme
une tragédie épouvantable etienne
leenhardt vous êtes à londres ce drame
cet accident on le redoutait presque
depuis que la princesse lady di été
l'objet d'une traque des journalistes
mais je n'ai pas bien entendu votre
question benoît mais ce qui est certain
et je crois que vous repreniez les mots
du premier ministre tony blair c'est que
tout le peuple britannique vit ce matin
le décès de la princesse diana comme une
tragédie une véritable tragédie le
premier ministre tony blair vous vous le
disiez parlé de tragédie accablante est
épouvantable une tragédie qui est à la
mesure de la popularité qui était celle
de la princesse diana
depuis des années et parmi toutes les
couches de la population parmi toutes
les générations même depuis son divorce
l'année dernière du prince charles un
communiqué laconique également de
buckingham palace la reine elizabeth et
le prince charles ont fait savoir il ya
quelques heures qu'ils étaient
profondément choquées et anéanties par
l'annoncé du décès de lady diana ses
enfants le prince william et le prince
harry qui sont âgés je vous le rappel de
16 ans et 15 ans sont en vacances
actuellement avec leur père dans leur
château de balmoral en écosse et il est
vraisemblable qu'il devrait rentrer à
londres dans la journée nous reviendrons
bien sûr dans le journal de 13h sur ses
réactions à londres quatre photographes
qui suivait la voiture de lady di sont
entendus en ce moment par la brigade de
criminels du quai des orfèvres l'enquète
dira qu'elle peut être éventuellement
leur responsabilité dans l'accident pour
l'instant aucune des motos de presse qui
suivait n'est impliqué directement dans
l'accident à 13h reviendrons bien sûr
très longuement sur ''les drame avec
bruno masure cet accident qui a donc vu
la mort je vous le disais de lady di de
son ami didier al-fayed et de leur
chauffeur bonne journée sur france 2
[Musique]